ladies and gentlemen
ben affleck thinks marvel's kevin feige
is the greatest producer ever breaking
news
ben affleck is gonna appear as daredevil
in spider-man 3 now
the uproar devil verse is coming next
persist
now and then we'll get colin farrell
back and we'll get
colin farrell back okay well let's see
what kevin
feige did not say let's see what ben
affleck had to say interview with
hollywood reporter
to which he said
kevin feige is absolutely you have to
say
the greatest producer most successful
producer who ever lived
he's the only guy in the world who if he
told me i know what the audience wants
this is what we're doing i would believe
him 100 percent
that [ __ ] knows his audience like no
producer
ever he's a genius kevin is like a ring
man he's really going here
kevin is like a ring master at the
circus he knows exactly how much to wink
at the audience
exactly want to pull out the
heartstrings exactly when to do the
effects
how many jokes what the sense of it
sounds like
you wanna you wanna switch universes man
what the tone is
because people didn't know to run away
from the pajamas or embrace it
or make it serious holy moly yeah that
was pajamas
sleep naked ben affleck look i don't
think he's wrong
i think kevin feige perhaps is our
greatest modern day producer
that we have i would say greatest i
don't think he's perfect
i don't think the mcu by any stretch
is a perfect franchise there's a couple
of those movies that i know
i'm not a big fan of let's face it in
terms of telling
the most cohesive cinematic universe in
terms of churning out the big numbers in
terms of keeping
audiences for the most part really
satisfied i know there's people already
clicking away
saying stuff like uh you know but
there's most of them are formulaic and
they're
kind of generic they follow the same
model all the time blah blah blah a lot
of them are good they're not great
yes i if that is your opinion that is
your opinion
you gotta look at though the masses you
gotta look at though the track record
you gotta look at the trajectory of
growth enthusiasm excitement
anticipation
yadda yadda but kevin feige has helped
shepherd what he has
led is pretty great i think the the
thing of why this
why this specific piece of news was
making the rounds
is because well he's zack snyder's
batman
yeah i mean while he has praise it's
zack snyder i mean this is a whole other
level of phrases a whole other one yeah
and it makes me wonder what zack snyder
must think reading this stuff and
and whether or not i mean like the
possibilities have opened up so wide and
even though we opened up with a joke
about like bringing in ben affleck's
daredevil about like the possibilities
have become so endless now that i almost
wonder if
he would be thrilled to do this i have
not seen the director's cut of daredevil
but i've heard
great things about it i'm obviously on
the side of look when daredevil
comes back i want it to be charlie cox
there are rumors going around that he
has rap filming on
spider-man 3 already that being said
this my mind did have me going through a
couple of things when i heard about this
zack snyder recently said that if there
was an mcu character he'd want to adapt
or
bring to life it would actually be
daredevil and
thinking about it i'm like well if
there's one character i think
zack snyder could actually pull off
within the mcu
i think it would be daredevil daredevil
would be the one with all the
catholic backdrop imagery the darkness
the anguish
the visuals the violence i'm like yeah
zack snyder actually would be a cool
pick
everyone who has seen the director's
code daredevil's like actually ben
affleck's pretty good in that one
so if there was some type of alternate
universe thingamajig that were to occur
of snyder and ben affleck redeeming for
a marvel property of
like to do daredevil that'd be pretty
neat yeah um
i don't think feige would ever do that i
don't think it would ever go down that
path
but in terms of fan fiction wish
fulfillment that's something where my
mind did go
immediately a lot of people do start
jumping on to the train am i
and i can't lie my mind kind of went
there too like i think he is just
praising him i don't think this is ben
affleck throwing
shade at dc i don't think that's at all
what it
is but if you want to compare the
producing department how many times have
they shifted
who the head is of the dc universe
within a few years in a direction
of the universe within the films and
everything else
and i did hear something about how i
think ben affleck was couldn't find it
before filming this video but ben
affleck talking about
how they did want to talk with feige
when it came time to
making daredevil to look for some
solutions because ben affleck has
dismissed that daredevil movie as
not being a good film but what he's
talking about here with knowing what the
audience
wants the heartstrings the humor when to
make it serious and what not to
i think majority of the time kevin feige
is
right on the money when it comes to all
these things i
would say i would i would absolutely
agree with these opinions of the
greatest
working producer today of my lifetime
who would have to be kevin feige and
i think he will go down in history as
one of the greatest movie producers
regardless of what
your personal opinion is about the mcu
or not
it's i think the track record and the
numbers speak for themselves
absolutely i mean the mcu is the
arguably
newest most innovative at least format a
revolutionary franchise
that we have experienced in our lifetime
and yeah he is largely responsible for
at least
a lot of that guidance and too i mean
looking across those films
even though there are missteps and
things like that he's shown himself
clearly capable
of recognizing what may have gone not
the
proper direction or in a direction that
didn't quite please the fans and
adjusting for that stuff whereas you
know dc seems to be
or you know warner brothers at large
seems to be very focused on
oh god what do the fans want would just
give them whatever they're yelling at us
about right now
and uh and yeah like it is a an
impressive amount of poise kevin feige
has been able to cultivate and i can see
why anybody would come out and just
express admiration
yeah i wouldn't be surprised if in some
shape or form because that afflict has
had a rough luck when it comes to
playing superheroes man
he got cast as daredevil stan lee i
remember the promotional time when
he was cast stanley being like when when
ben affleck was cast
that was who i imagined matt murdock to
look like was ben
affleck that didn't turn out so well he
gets cast as batman he gets all the
backlash and then bam he comes out
and bvs everyone's like who's the best
part of batman be superman
and you see how many people are
championing him for him to continue on
as batman in some way
like he's gonna be in the flashpoint
movie but maybe
continue on with some snyder films or
some series within the hbo max world
yeah
i think though ben affleck's making it
pretty clear
he'd love to work with kevin you got it
i know you got people on tv you just
signed ethan hawk to something bring me
in man kevin feige's working on that
star wars movie maybe he can get inside
of a star wars film or something like
that
either way i mean i'd just be happy for
the guy but netflix become this
personality that i'm constantly rooting
for just hear
that
everything is like he's he's an
interesting celebrity
to follow i want him to just have that
one thing that is
solid and concrete man he needs it or
maybe he's opting to direct an mcu film
or something hey that could be cool
that'd be cool to see ben affleck hop
into that hey man get jennifer garner
out here praising kevin feige they can
bring a lecture back yeah
i can direct that well guys do you agree
with ben affleck
do you think he had an agenda here with
trying to get himself
involved directly with working with the
greatest producer of all time leave your
thoughts down below subscribe
click that notification bell hit that
like button catch you guys soon
[Music]